what would you say are your top two or
three talents I'm good at persuading I'm
pretty good at resource allocation if we
have limited resources and time and
money and bandwidth or attention and we
have unlimited options that we have that
the world presents us we have to learn
to say no to 99.99 of things truly
because options are unlimited resources
are and so the ability to allocate
resources I think for me has allowed me
to move through things quickly I've been
able to move quickly through life
because I've been able to allocate my
energy into the highest leverage
activities the things that I get the
most return on for my time